say like the most dangerous people in
the world right now are lonely sexless
men sitting in their basement so to
speak and if you are just home on your
phone and everyone out there is living
their best life and you just buy
yourself and you're a 16 year old kid 22
year old kid 24 year old guy whatever it
is and everyone's having a great time
and you're home alone and you're doing
some sort of drug by yourself I think
social media has led to that and then I
think what is even worse as you can see
was trending upward and then since covet
it is just skyrocketed and that's sad
because what you don't hear people
saying is get the hell out of your house
exercise go hang out with friends be a
human get out there like thank you and
you don't hear people talking about that
foreign
[Music]